San franciscans say no taxation until
you fix the homeless situation and if
the pandemic had you stressing Rogan
says teach the Dems a lesson business
owners in one San Francisco neighborhood
are threatening to stop paying taxes if
the city doesn't do something about its
homelessness problem
125 local businesses in the city's
Castro section recently wrote a letter
to City officials saying they're fed up
that it's hurt their bottom line way too
much which is what Greg told his staff
when they simply asked for air
conditioning and bathroom breaks
so they're done paying taxes unless
their demands are met including 35
shelter beds monthly data on the
services offered to the homeless and a
plan for what to do with people who
decline help said one local business
leader whatever they're doing it isn't
working which is the same thing comedy
agents have been telling Jimmy for years
a lot of tough love a lot of tough love
for the champ today
speaking of what to do when things
aren't working on his podcast this week
Joe Rogan said there's only one way to
hold officials accountable for their
mistakes in handling the pandemic
I hope there's Lessons Learned in this
no one who is alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic
and I'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to you know
recognize that some serious errors were
made and not repeat those that's the
best you can get out of it so what do
you tell those people vote Republican
that's what a lot of them are going to
do anyway
so he's probably right on that one
although Nancy Pelosi did some fine work
during the cholera pandemic of 1822 you
might not have heard about that but we
looked into it today
and after these failed lockdowns the
only thing worth repeating is third
grade
for more let's check in with gutfeld's
new political correspondence if you've
seen these guys Mike and Jake bananas
fellas what's your prediction for the
midterms
[Music]
really looking forward to those guys
filling in on the five
Stephen that'll be fun Jimmy on the San
Francisco story a short wise man named
Greg once said this is what happens when
you get one party towns without loyal
opposition you get Revolt like not
paying your taxes well that's what
happened is they were rooting for their
party instead of their quality of life
like that's what's gone on in New York
New York and San Francisco are the
world's two biggest outdoor restrooms
that's not a good thing but why is it
there it's been there for years now but
people wanted their party to get a win
so they didn't actually hold anyone
accountable to the point now where it's
actually kind of too late because
businesses holding out isn't going to
help it's just going to pass the bill on
to us with those 87 000 new IRS agents
they're not going to pay Jimmy phela is
going to get audited for a fourth time
because apparently you can't write off
gay magician shirts I didn't know that
was a thing where were you Turbo Tax
when I needed you is that what they call
it Flushing Meadows yeah maybe Julian in
The Green Room you said I love San
Francisco and agree with the politicians
in California
I actually love this idea I want to
rebate for every homeless stoned person
in the city exhaling their second-hand
smoke in my face I could actually Save A
Buck or two the politicians in San
Francisco though I think they're stoned
honestly because the homeless situation
in San Francisco San Francisco I mean
look at Los Angeles and look at every
democratic-led city in this entire
country if you look at it by crime
homelessness drugs we should be getting
a discount I want a discount I don't
mean the five finger discount I used to
take advantage of when I was 15. but you
know like some kind of rebate something
or like I have a competence that would
be good for your investment yeah sure so
then from the business perspective how
does the scourge of homelessness affect
you know your small business owners and
these like these 125 businesses in
Castro distance these poor folks you
know I read their comments you know
they're they're taking poo off of the
sidewalk in front of their building
that's from human beings not from dogs
they're moving the homeless away from
their doorstep look here's what's going
to happen we've seen it here in New York
City people get frustrated they can't
make money they don't like their lives
they leave they will leave the Castro
District because they can't make money
there it's a simple thing and the city
father should do everything they can to
support these small businesses not to
stand in their way so Joey what solution
would you suggest to resolve the issue
do you have one I think the real estate
market over at Alcatraz is probably
pretty big right now right like you get
an island of your own like you've got
spacious there's not a lot of bumps can
get there uh listen at the end of the
day you get what you ask for you get
what you vote for you get what you've
advocated for and if you don't like it
that might be time to do some soul
searching and say okay well maybe this
wasn't the way uh you know I'm a big
Edgar Allan Poe fan uh Jimmy's more of a
David Allan Coe fan
we're calling him Little Jimmy Dickens
tonight you know
um but you know there's a he's got a
short story or a poem talks about the
pit in the pendulum and the idea that
the pendulum swings both ways and that
pendulum has been pulled so far left in
places like San Francisco It's Gonna Cut
Loose it's gonna swing back and people
are going to push back against it
um it's just what will be left of the
City by that time won't be left of this
country by the time that some of these
cities figure it out that's what you
know we talked on the five yesterday
about what what I call or we talked on
your show this morning actually about
what I call the quiet crime crisis of
cities that aren't named San Francisco
Los Angeles Chicago and New York these
problems are happening everywhere they
just not every city out there has the
opportunity to get the attention that
these do and uh and so San Francisco for
now is taking up space on the headlines
because it used to be a beautiful city
and now it's a beautiful mess Denver's
another one that I'm familiar with uh
Jimmy do you think that Rogan is right
that people will think about not just
crime but also just what happened in the
last few years with the lockdowns that
they'll want to vote Republican in
November I think a lot of people are
because I don't think the Democrats have
read the room on how much coveted
frustration there is people are sick of
it they hated the lockdowns they hated
the hypocrisy I mean think San Francisco
is one of the epicenters for covet
hypocrisy if you remember when their
mayor implemented a lockdown she got
caught at a nightclub the next day and
said she was feeling the spirit so she
didn't have to wear a mask or be locked
down now I know covet's a sophisticated
virus when they made it in the lab but I
don't know if that was a music exemption
I don't know I don't it's really weird
I haven't been to Beijing in a while but
I don't remember the disco scene as
being very big over there you know what
I mean but I don't appreciate all the
cheap shots of Jimmy Johnny Joey there's
a lot of cheap shot if we're gonna get
into a a dissing contest you don't have
a leg to stand on
[Laughter]
the
military
I knew Joey would have the last word hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else